welcome everyone um uh welcome to this
simon's institute uh theoretically
speaking panel
uh it's a discussion on adversarial
examples in in deep learning
uh my name is peter bartlett and the
simon's institute for the theory of
computing
is
a collaborative research institute in
theoretical computer science
established in 2012 with a grant from
the simons foundation
we bring together the world's leading
researchers in tcs and related fields as
well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars
to explore the laws of computation and
the use of algorithmic thinking
in science and engineering and society
and today's panel discussion is part of
our theoretically speaking
public series
which highlights exciting scientific and
computational advances for a broad
audience
and the topic today adversarial examples
in deep learning
is certainly a very broad interest it'll
be an exciting exciting discussion uh
our moderator today is anil anantha
swami who's had several stints here at
the summers institute as our science
communicator in residence anil is a
freelance science journalist a former
staff writer and deputy news editor for
new scientist magazine
and a former mit night science
journalism fellow
and neil contributes regularly to
quantum magazine
and scientific american and he's the
author of three popular science books uh
the edge of physics the man who wasn't
there and through two doors at once and
anil is currently writing a book on the
mathematics of machine learning
so welcome anil
thank you peter for that introduction
and uh welcome to our audience uh
wherever you are
um
and welcome to our panelist i'm just
going to share my screen now
let me see
so um yes welcome to everyone
to this panel discussion on
adversarial examples in deep learning it
is a privilege to be able to introduce
our panelists and in a particular order
assuming i can get my powerpoint to work
here
there
we have with us dr sebastian bubeck
sebastian is a senior principal research
manager
in machine learning foundations at
microsoft research in redmond washington
he has worked extensively on adversarial
examples in machine learning including
studies of computational complexity
of adversarial examples and the
development of a law of robustness which
we are going to hear about today
it's a theory of the relation between
the size of machine learning models and
their ability to withstand adversarial
attacks
uh so welcome sebastian
thank you very much
uh we also have with us with uh uh dr
melanie mitchell uh melanie is the davis
professor at the santa fe institute in
new mexico
her current research focuses on
conceptual abstraction analogy making
visual recognition in ai and ai safety
and we're going to hear a fair bit about
ai safety in the context of adversarial
examples from her she's the author or
editor of six books and numerous papers
in ai cognitive science and complex
systems our latest book is artificial
intelligence a guide for thinking humans
so welcome melanie
thank you
nice to be here
and we also have with us dr lawrence
vander marten
lawrence is a research director at meta
ai
and formerly he was assistant professor
at delft university of technology in
delft netherlands his research interests
include machine learning and computer
vision
he's currently working on embedding
models large scale weekly supervised
learning visual reasoning and cost
sensitive learning
and lawrence uh will bring a unique
perspective both from uh his academic
work and
from being the research director at a
major social media company when it comes
to thinking about adversarial examples
um
so again welcome all of you um before uh
we get started with questions for each
one of you to get the discussion going i
just wanted to share a couple of slides
uh with our audience to just make sure
that
we give them a roadmap of what we're
going to be discussing much of our
discussion today will be about deep
neural networks which as most people in
the audience will
know that
they are basically
machine learning systems uh
composed of computational units called
artificial neurons they're arranged into
layers
and the figure that you see on the
screen is showing you one such network
where there's an input coming from the
left side the input can be for instance
uh
you know the pixel values of an image
and then you have an output which could
be a number which categorizes
that input
says the image of a cat or a dog or what
have you um and of course your inputs
and outputs can be designed uh
specifically to perform a particular
task that you have in mind
there are also lots of layers within the
network between the input and output
layers these are so called hidden layers
and the more the hidden layers the
deeper the neural network we might also
encounter technology
such as feed forward networks which
simply refers to the idea that the
information in a neural network
flows one way from the input to the
output we will most certainly come
across a term convolutional neural
networks or cnns which are a particular
architecture of artificial neural
networks dedicated for not dedicated but
specialized for image recognition
uh we may hear about transformers uh
which are all the rage now uh we might
also hear about the current neural
networks which
have feedback connections so the
information flow is not just from the
input to the output but there's feedback
we will most certainly hear about deep
learning a method to train deep neural
networks
to perform
certain tasks given data so
that's just a very quick and dirty
introduction
and we come to the
brief
sort of take on adversarial examples
itself i just wanted to show you some
pretty pictures to get started but this
is the
term that will be explored in detail by
our panelists
what you see on the screen
uh two rows of
images
the left
image in each row is an unaltered image
you have an image of a insect and a dog
and on the right side
you have uh
the same image which has been altered
with the addition of some noise and in
the middle panel you see the noise which
has been amplified about 10 times for us
to be able to see
the crucial thing here
is that the image on the right
to us humans looks no different from the
image on the left
despite the noise that has been added
but this uh these images on the right
were specifically constructed
to fool a network called alexnet alexnet
as many of you would know was the
network that won the image recognition
contest in 2012 and because of which
deep learning and deep neural networks
became all the rage
but in the context of this particular
set of adversarial examples or
examples or images that have been
altered alexnet ends up classifying them
as ostriches
and to us they look like exactly the
same images before they were altered and
these are examples of adversarial
images
so
our panelists will get into this in so
much more detail i just wanted to
put it out there so that you know what
to expect
and uh
over the course of the
panel discussion i hope that we will
address many if not all of these issues
what exactly are adversarial examples
how do we generate them
why are deep neural networks susceptible
to adversarial examples what are the
dangers of such adversarial attacks on
neural networks
and can such examples be used to better
understand neural networks and how they
work
and if time permits and and i hope we
can get to this which what is the
connection between various intriguing
and not very well understood properties
of deep neural networks such as the
generalization which is the ability to
adapt to unseen data drawn from the same
distribution as the training data
robustness the idea that small
perturbations in inputs shouldn't leave
two massive changes in output
uh
the relationship all this to accuracy of
a neural network
on a task that it's been designed for
and what's the size of a neural network
or the size of a machine learning model
got to do
with questions of generalization and
robustness particularly robustness to
uh against adversarial attacks and
brazil examples so i will stop sharing
my screen now and uh
and basically uh to get this going i
would uh like to ask
each one of you a question to get us
started and melanie may start with you
before we talk about adversarial
examples in ai
can you tell us about any such
susceptibility in humans is our vision
human vision capable of being fooled and
if so why
and how has that knowledge been used to
understand uh primate vision or human
vision
yeah so uh
i'll start my answer by by a quote i
really like from the psychologist donald
hoffman who says vision in
humans and primates and other systems
has evolved to guide adaptive behavior
not to report truth
so it's absolutely the fact that our
vision visual systems can be fooled if
you like i'm going to share
a couple of slides here just as examples
of visual illusions
um
you can see that right
yeah
yeah so so these are probably very
familiar to a lot of people this is a
famous one one um where uh the squares
marked a and b are actually the same
shade of gray but they look different to
us
because we interpret
uh
the shadow here we interpret this as a
shadow that and so therefore our visual
system lightens for our interpretation
the bee to to to to take account of the
shadow so
we use our knowledge and our
expectations
in certain ways that give us robustness
in the real world but that allow the
construction of these kinds of optical
illusions to fool us
uh you know another famous one
can i ask you just is there any way for
us to be convinced that this was
actually the same shade of gray like do
we just have to believe you or can we
hide some part of the image and see that
it's the same shade um i think there are
you know you could hide i don't have uh
an
illustration of that but yes there are
ways to convince yourself that these are
the same
um
similarly um these two uh tables look
like they have very different shapes and
yet if you you can actually rotate
um the one on the right and show that
the shape is exactly the same as the top
on the left and the reason that we
perceive them as different shapes is
because we can't avoid projecting into
three dimensions you know in two
dimensions if you you know just rotate
this two-dimensional
shape it's exactly the same but our
visual systems are just primed to
project these kinds of images into three
dimensions we can't help ourselves but
that's actually part of the reason we
can survive well in the world
you know we have these uh
so-called gestalt
uh
prior
preferences in our visual system that um
force us to see for instance this
illusory triangle
because of our desire to
complete
contours to complete uh shapes
and you know we also
the famous necker cube here in which you
can
sort of visually
interpret it in two different ways the
the the cube um oriented in um
one way to another we can't see them the
both at the same time but our
our cysts are it's like an instantaneous
switch
that shows how fast our
interpretation of a whole
view
uh
is has to be consistent
similarly this is a famous um
illusion where you either see
uh a young woman turning away from you
or an old woman
uh in profile i don't you know when i
first saw it i could not see the old
woman i only could see the young woman
but if you focus on the mouth
here this is the mouth of the old woman
this is her chin
this is her eye
hopefully you can see my mouse here
and maybe the whole image will just flip
so these these are um examples
oh
let's see
i have to unshare
yeah so these are examples of how the
machinery of the visual system
processes the light that comes in
through the retina goes through
the brain to the back of the brain the
visual cortex and that's also how it's
influenced by
higher level cognition
so
visual illusions in this case
reveal a lot about the processing that
our brain does
and they can all be explained
due to useful very robust mechanisms
that we use for understanding the world
and for understanding typical visual
statistics that are then played on to
fool us in these visual illusions
so i i want to say you know i think
we're going to talk about adversarial
examples and many
how many people have kind of compared
them as
analogous to visual illusions for humans
but i think there's some very
significant differences
first we can't we humans
and other animals also see some visual
illusions in the same way that we do
especially
chimps who have very similar visual
systems
there's been a lot of experimental
evidence
for that um
but with respect to um our visual
illusions we we really cannot be fooled
in ways that are important for our
evolutionary survival
and that's because these systems have
evolved you know our visual system has
evolved
to allow us to survive in in the
environment that we live in and
therefore we're very robust for
tasks that
impact our survival but we can be fooled
in in
non-non-critical tasks
whereas in deep neural networks and
other machine learning systems
adversarial examples
are really have nothing to do with the
evolutionary benefit of the system
in any sense and i think that they show
a lack of robustness
rather than showing robustness which is
i believe what uh
optical illusions do for us they show
how our systems are robust in certain
ways
um they also uh are affected by the
dynamics of vision you know in our
visual system vision happens over a time
course
which in uh
deep most deep neural networks
especially feed forward ones there's no
time course of vision and so there's a
big difference in what kinds of
robustness that time course gives us
and i'll say that um
adversarial examples in for machine
learning systems have many more degrees
of freedom you know
you could never convince
a human that a
picture of that a dog like we saw is an
ostrich
and yet with adversarial examples in in
machine learning you can really take any
any adversary can take any
sort of category that the network knows
about and fool the system and thinking
it's seeing that category so i'll stop
there i hope that gave some insight into
what visual illusions are how they tell
us something about our visual system and
how they're different from adversarial
examples
thank you melanie that was wonderful
so sebastian given given melanie's
introduction to
how this might operate in human vision
and how it's different from adversarial
examples and deep learning can you tell
us about adversarial examples in deep
learning like are they restricted for
instance to computer vision or do they
exist in deep nets that work on other
kinds of data
such as audio or text
yeah and you know have there been uh
particular examples that have intrigued
you maybe even scared you yeah sure of
course i mean the answer is yes to that
last one
so maybe let me
share my screen also
with the sound
okay
so um so this is the same image that
anil was uh showing before basically um
it's an image of a peak and you see you
add a little bit of noise and then
suddenly the you know neural network
thinks that it's a an airliner and so
again this is an
image in the visual setting that we have
seen
so far you know the joke that my friend
alexander madrid likes to tell is that
you know neural networks are so great
that they can make a pig fly okay so
this is uh this is the story of this
slide and there are a couple of uh
clarifications that i want to make
before i i answer anil's question about
the multi modality the first one is i
wholeheartedly agree with melanie and
her comments about the difference
between you know optical illusions and
adversarial examples and probably for me
the most important one is that optical
illusions they are carefully crafted
like it's not like you can take a random
scenery and then apply a perturbation to
it and it will fool the human visual
system whereas for neural networks it's
literally on any image on basically any
input you can modify it and completely
fool the neural network so that's a huge
huge uh you know difference for me the
other clarification that i want to make
to set the expectations for for the
audience is that we don't have the
answer to address our example this
remains to me one of the major open
problem in deep learning is how do we
build systems that are not susceptible
or less susceptible to adverse example
we have some tiny progress on it but
this picture that i'm showing on this
slide you know i the title is after
decades of work you know this is a
status this is true today okay nobody
knows how to uh remove uh this effect
okay so it's a it's a really a major
open problem and i i hope this you know
panel uh will will make some people in
the audience excited to work on it and
maybe solve it okay so now let me move
on to answer a news question about
whether you know adversary examples are
limited to
visual examples and the answer is of
course no so here are a few examples one
is going to be again visual but i will
explain the difference one is going to
be about text and one is going to be
about audio
so this image that you see is you know a
detector that is supposed to detect
human beings and you see that the
detector works perfectly well so it's a
cnn a convolutional neural network and
it detects this person but it does not
detect that person why because that
person is wearing this kind of cloak of
invisibility for neural network which is
an adversarial poster and one key thing
you know there is a video online of this
picture one key thing is that this
poster is an adversarial example which
is robust to slight movement so the
person can move you know it doesn't have
to be exactly in this frame the person
can move and the poster will remain an
adversarial example so you understand
that that means that the perturbation
itself is robust so so that's you know
something very interesting and you can
imagine you know
what it means to to be able to develop a
clock of invisibility for these
detectors you know i will let maybe the
other panelists tell us about what that
could potentially mean
then next is uh you know an example in
natural language processing so i have
three tasks spam filtering sentiment
analysis and fake news detection and i
will just briefly you know show you what
happens so this is some lstm okay it's
some neural network that tells you that
it's 100 sure that it's a spam so the
original text was your application has
been accepted thank you for your loan
request blah blah blah and now what you
can do is you can just find synonym for
a few of those words you can replace
application by petition you can replace
accepted by recognized so now it is like
your petition has been recognized thank
you for your borrower blah blah blah and
now it's 99 it's 89 sorry percent sure
that it's non-spam so just by changing a
few words you were able to fool the
detector okay same thing for the
sentiment analysis i won't read it and
let me just spend uh 20 seconds on the
fake news detection because of course
you know this is of a tremendous
importance nowadays so here was the
original test text where the classifier
was 97 percent sure that it was fake
trump supporter who's brutal beating
blah blah blah
now you just change brutal by ferocious
you change mob by gangsta you change a
few words like this and now it's 100
sure that it's real it completely falls
you know the fake news detector so you
can imagine the consequences of this so
this is you know an example in uh in
text now i'll give you an example in
audio and and uh i think it's pretty
thought-provoking at least for me so let
me
start the video so this is somebody who
is going to talk to alexa and i you will
see that alexa just works perfectly well
but then he's going to play an
adversarial music which basically acts
exactly as the cloak of invisibility was
acting you know on the left meaning that
once the adversary music is playing
alexa will not
okay so let's so you see like it's life
it works
it turns on but now
[Music]
it's not the fact that the sound is too
big and it you know overcome the voice
of the person it's really like it
interferes with the neural network and
it removes you know the sound for the
neural network uh so i think that's you
know how i would answer your question
anil about the different modalities
basically address that example they
exist for any type of neural networks
they exist all the time
and you mentioned something that scared
you at some point but what which one was
that
you know i i find the fake news detector
uh you know fooling the fake news
detector it's like the implications for
this are just you know uh pretty crazy
in my opinion
thank you thank you very much uh
so lawrence
given
what
melanie and sebastian have said i
when i was talking to you earlier
you had mentioned that when you started
working on adversarial examples you were
intrigued by their potential right so uh
and and that impression has changed over
uh the last few years for you but what
did you see in them that got you
interested to begin with in in terms of
like in was it their potential to
understand neural networks or
like what was it
yeah i think thanks so much i think
that's that's a great question um i mean
i mean you mentioned the um the original
uh paper by i think uh christian
secretary right this came out in in 2014
it was kind of the first time that
that people observed um some of these
effects in uh in neural networks um this
was about two years after alex snatch
rights uh which was sort of the the
first model that
you know convinced i think a large part
of the uh the machine learning community
that there was really
merits uh to deep learning right in
particular in in perceptual tasks and so
there was a lot of excitement around
uh these models you know sort of every
few months they were getting better in
terms of um in terms of accuracy and i
think this was one of one of the first
studies that uh that showed um or that
displayed some of the limitations um of
these models right and and you know like
the examples that i think sebastian just
showed like they're they're just really
intriguing right it's like they want to
they sort of pull you in and you want to
like understand what's uh what's going
on here right uh they tell you something
right like they tell you that um you
know deep networks
they somehow you know the way they solve
the the recognition tasks that you ask
them to do they somehow do it
differently uh from from sort of how the
human brain does it right it's like i
think melanie should show beautiful
examples of like
uh
of visual illusions right like where
you know you maybe sort of get to the
edge of like
uh where the the the human visual system
um starts to be unsure i guess right
about what the input is or or
you know sort of ends up sort of in a
bimodal state i suppose right like where
there are sort of two possible
um outcomes that it's switching between
and it's clear that in deep networks you
know so that there are other things um
um that are happening right and so this
raises a lot of uh questions it's both
from
sort of an understanding point of view
right it's like hey you know
if you see this like it it tells you
something about how these networks are
operating right like about what these
networks are doing it gives you some
kind of signal and maybe the signal and
i'm sure we'll get into that more in in
detail right but the signal that it
gives you is that
um if you can do
a very small change um on the inputs
right and have that result in a very
large change on the outputs right like
what that means is that sort of the
function that this that this model uh
represents
is is a rapidly changing thing right for
example that uh that is one of the
things that it um that it suggests and
i'm sure we'll we'll dive more into that
uh sebastian has done a lot of uh
amazing analysis on um
on that part
the other part that that's intriguing is
sort of around say what are the
practical implications of this um i'm uh
i'm not at all a theorist uh myself so i
never expected to to end up in this uh
this panel very excited to be here with
with various team colleagues
um i'm i'm more of an empiricist i like
to
build models and systems that actually
work
right and so i'm always looking for
what are what are things that break our
systems right and and clearly here's a
thing that
that breaks our system and so that is a
that is a potential concern right like
that's something that we should look
into seek to seek to understand and not
just sort of how it happens and what we
can do about it uh but also to what
extent is it a um is this a real uh uh
problem right or is there sort of a
uh a larger phenomena here or um um that
that is sort of underlying it um and so
i was i was super intrigued uh
did a bunch of work uh myself in this
space more empirical work
uh than than for example uh sebastian
has has done uh mostly focused on the
defense sites right
what's a little bit ironic is that in
the
academic literature uh i i think if you
were sort of to classify papers into
adversarial developing adversarial
attacks
and developing defenses against
adversarial attacks i think you'll find
like a hundred attack papers for every
defense paper which is a little odd
right uh given that
you know sort of the adversary is
typically like the bad guy right like
that's the guy who wants to get the um
um
the uh the the fake news onto like you
know sort of your favorite social
network or um or or what not
and um you know the and so i've mostly
been working on the defense sides and i
think their
my conclusion is kind of and i think
that you know we'll we'll get to this is
that there's kind of
doesn't seem to be a whole lot of hope
um
from the from the empirical point of
view um
as well as
you know and we'll get to that i think
on the theoretical side there are also
some some suggestions that there's
there's not a lot of hope so like
on the one hand that sounds very
um
you know concerning right or like uh uh
uh
uh or scary at the same time i think
if uh at least sort of in the in the
cases that i've seen sort of uh the
practical implications and the sort of
practical security risks of these things
i think are
um
you know not as large maybe as um as
people think or i would say
you know for
every sort of adversarial attack there
are a hundreds more primitive attacks
that work just as well
and and are much easier to implement by
sort of any adversary who's trying to uh
who's trying to fool a system and so
you know like at the same time i've also
become
less concerned uh about them and and i
sort of think about these adversarial
examples a little bit more as sort of an
academic curiosity now
um and so in my own work over time i've
sort of transitioned to focusing more on
what i would describe more as like
natural robustness right so like
robustness to
uh like like to situations where
a
um
where deep networks don't produce the
right results
even on images that are not like you
know uh
adversarially crafted
but that just happened to be you know
taken in another country or
uh
you know some some sort of like natural
uh uh variation
and what i've observed is that sort of
empirically you know um and and not just
me but but many others uh systems
struggle with even just the natural uh
robustness
to sort of variations that exist in the
world and from a
sort of system builder perspective from
a like hey i want this image recognition
model to work as good as possible
um i i think that's sort of a probably a
bigger concern than uh
than the adversarial um example so
that's a little bit the trajectory i've
had sort of over the past uh five six
years in this in this space
great thank you i'm sure
there are many points of discussion
between all three of you in what
lawrence just said
um but but one thing that comes to mind
for me and i'm sure our audience is also
thinking if one of you could briefly
tell us how do you even design
adversarial examples like is there a
process you follow
um you know can you can you design you
know very specific kinds of examples or
is it a
you know shooting in the dark like let's
see what comes up kind of approach
so um sebastian do you want to check
that yeah sure i can answer that but
maybe i just want to say about what
lauren said again i i agree with
everything that he said
um
one in particular you know natural
robustness is a is a you know a good a
better avenue to make uh you know uh
faster progress at the moment etc but
one thing that it made me think about
you know that when he said that he's
less scared about adversary examples now
and and i knew you were asking me about
one you know scary situation that i have
encountered and yeah i i was just
reminded of an example so it's not out
there
yet you know it doesn't exist but i
think in the future you could imagine
like adversary example kind of as a
service what i mean by that is imagine
that you know tomorrow bank of america
or some big bank you know design a
neural network system that decides you
know whether your loan application is
going to be accepted or not so it just
you know takes in all the file processes
it and then decide whether it can be
accepted or not and imagine that you
know i'm an adversary example crafter
and somehow i have access to the neural
networks that bank of america is using
and i'm able to craft that personal
example so you can ask me you know hey
can you help me to craft my application
can you put the coma just in the right
place so as to maximize my chance of
being accepted now imagine this you know
being used in college admission or you
know wherever and and i think there is a
real risk there in the future so this
adversary example as a service you know
there is a potential for it in the
future which is kind of a little bit
scary um
so okay so that was one thing that i
want to say the other one is you asked
about how do you actually craft those
addresses examples so let me
share my slides again
i have an example of this
right here
all right yeah
so okay so so it will take you know
three minutes but but just so that
everybody is on the same page on how do
you do those things because it's
actually extremely simple you know one
of the key point is that the leader
later
the literature universal example even
though it's kind of important it's not
very deep yet like we don't there's so
many things that we don't understand
that it's very very easy to explain
everything that we actually know so
again on our network as i nearly
explained before you know you have some
input image like an x and then the
neural network it's a bunch of ways that
processes it and then you know the
output whether it's a pig or whatever
it's some function f that depends on x
the input and that depends on theta
theta is the set of weight in this
now there are two
gradients that matter when you think
about neural networks and gradients just
mean it's just a sensitivity analysis so
the two gradients are whether you're
changing the parameter theta or whether
you're changing the parameter x so the
most natural type of gradient the one
that people use to actually train our
network is to understand how the how the
output of the neural network is
sensitive to changing the weights you
want to know when i change the weight
how does the function change and then
learning is all about changing those
weights as you see more and more
examples okay so the gradient with
respect to data that the sensitivity to
the network parameter now the gradient
with respect to x
that's the sensitivity of the output
with respect to the input it's how what
happens when you change you know some
pixel value in x how does it change you
know the output and so the gradient with
respect to the input it has itself an
image interpretation you know the values
that i see in this picture is how much
the output change when i change the
corresponding pixel okay now how do you
craft adversarial examples so again
classical training is you update your
model with the gradient with respect to
the parameter how how does it change
when you change one of the parameter
adversarial training it's like this you
take your x your input x and you want
just to change the output as much as
possible and to change the output as
much as possible you're just going to
move in the direction of the gradient
itself so the adversary perturbation is
nothing but
the gradient with respect to the input
that's how you find an adversarial
perturbation that's it it's as easy as
that so you just compute the gradient
with respect to the input and that's how
you find you know this noise like image
that you're going to add to your input
and let me just briefly mention that you
know this you can actually be kind of
robust with respect to this single step
uh you know attack but what you can do
is you know actually do many steps of
gradient so not only do you apply the
gradient one time you apply the gradient
many many times and that will give you a
better adverse perturbation so this
slide this is it this is how you find
the adversary examples
that that sounds uh very simple in the
sense that a lot of people could be
doing this pretty easily but um
um
melanie i i you know you have
you've been looking at uh
adversarial examples as a way to really
probe our understanding of these black
boxes
so could you talk a little bit about uh
you know sort of the positive side of
what you know we're going to come more
and more to talking about
uh what we should be afraid of if if at
all uh i know lawrence doesn't uh feel
the same but um
but from the positive perspective like
wha what are you able to probe about
deep neural networks given uh
adversarial
examples
well
so i think there's a lot of things we
can probe
one of them is how how the
neural networks represent
visual information um
in a way that's quite different from the
way humans seem to represent it
so we can look at the representations
that these networks um
produce and
we can look at how they
represent
uh you know a
an image to which they give the correct
answer versus the representation of an
image to which they give an incorrect
answer and we can say how do those
differ you know what and and
you know humans typically don't see a
difference at least in these examples
that that we've shown so far um
and i think there's a lot of big
difference you know this really
highlights differences in the way that
we
see the world and the way neural
networks see the world you know we and
also how we learn to see the world
versus how neural networks learn to see
the world you know
we
are
see the world in 3d as as
you know the some of these exam
optical illusions really show
there's in the way that neural networks
are usually trained for things like
image recognition there's no
push or prior for the network to
interpret the images as a
three-dimensional
image and and
it's
it also shows like how sensitive these
networks are to things like particular
textures
in the image and how
the there's
as opposed to to more robust kinds of of
of uh features
that might prince might might involve
more shape-based representations um
and and also that that you know neural
networks for the most part are
completely feed forward
uh the the ones that people use in in
for visual tasks you know recurrent
networks have a sort of
limited amount of feedback
but in humans
the visual system has 10 times more
feedback connections and it has feed
forward connections
and that's something that i think has is
relevant to um understanding our
robustness you know our vision system is
very much
influenced by
more top-down processes
involving cognition
and not
solely restricted to bottom-up kind of
feed-forward
representations and processes so i think
all of those really show the this
some ways in which we might look to the
um
biological brains
as a kind of inspiration for making our
neural networks more robust
and
but do these uh adversarial examples
already reveal like i i remember when we
talked you talked about uh you know
building systems where you can build
neural networks to generate adversarial
examples that are transferable
right right right so does that tell you
like being able to do that does that
tell you more about how deep nets work
in general
yeah so so that's an interesting fact
about
adversarial examples you know you you um
you you can
you design them as sebastian showed you
design them with respect to a particular
neural network and its weights so you're
doing a you know kind of a gradient
descent on the image itself
with respect to a particular neural
network
but it turns out that
those
adversarial examples that that generates
are often
transferable to other neural networks
with different weights
and even with different architectures
such as you know
convolutional neural networks versus
transformers
and
that shows
interestingly that somehow the
representations being learned by these
different neural networks are have some
universality there's some thing in
common that allows the same adversarial
example to fool all of them in the same
way
and so it's really interesting to look
at different architectures and see
which ones generate the most
kind of transferable adversarial
examples and that tells you about
something about sort of what
representations are shared among all
these different neural networks
but as sebastian said i think we don't
we still don't fully understand
everything about
why these network these exam adversary
examples are
fooling these systems and why certain
ones are more transferable than others
so that's still an open question
in fact you can even transfer across
inputs not only across architectures but
also across inputs you can find
universal perturbations that perturb you
know kind of every input which is also
yeah but but to find those things it's
more complicated than just the gradient
i showed
and i think you know one thing to point
out is um i think i saw this in the
question
uh in the
uh question section that um
you know we have what are called white
box attacks and black box attacks the
white block box attacks are ones in
which the attacker knows the details of
the neural network and the black box
attacks are where the attacker does not
know the details they might not know the
weights of the network or they might not
even know the specific architecture of
the network but um and so obviously
white box attacks are easier to create
but if we have transferable uh examples
then we can attack black networks in a
black box way also
[Music]
so all you know from all that you're
saying it
does sound like a problem that has to be
dealt with but based on you know uh
what lawrence said so maybe this is we
can go back to lawrence now uh
to give us uh your perspective as
someone who's
you know
working in trying to actually actively
mitigate these concerns uh
and you see them quite differently so
let's let's get talking more about
uh
your perspective in the field and in
terms of the threats you perceive uh to
machine learning systems and where these
kind of concerns
you know uh lie on the totem pole of
threats
right right so so to be clear like i
don't actively work on these uh but but
here's sort of my take on it right like
what you said and you know when when
sebastian explained how to generate uh
an adversarial uh example like you said
like wow that is
uh that is pretty easy right like that
is pretty easy to do and i would
i would challenge that a little bit uh
in the sense that yes i you know like
it's easy for sort of the people in this
room and and in the audience but like as
a general thing
um there are a bunch of things that you
need to be able to do right like in uh
one you need to have um access to
the model that you are uh
that you are attacking right so like the
example that sebastian showed was sort
of a white box
um attack of course like you can do
black box attacks but they're
you know like the way you do it is
basically this this gradient that
sebastian was was using in order to
change the input what you're going to do
is you're you're going to approximate
that's basically by doing like zero zero
daughter uh order approximations rights
and you can do that pretty efficiently
because you know images are sort of
relatively uh low dimensional and so
like you don't need to do something like
coordinate descend over every pixel you
can do it in some low dimensional space
but you still need a few hundred tries
in order to sort of get to your um
get to your adversarial example
um now of course like that seems easy
but i would say like let's say for the
fake news example that uh that sebastian
showed i can think of much more
primitive attacks that will be very
successful
so for example i would invite sebastian
to make a screenshot of the original
text
and to upload it onto you know one of
his uh favorite social networks and i
can guarantee you
that uh it will go straight through
right and so now we have an attack
that my mom can do right and my mom
knows absolutely nothing about you know
deep networks or fake news detection and
is definitely incapable of of staging an
adversarial attack
uh another thing that sebastian could do
is he could take the original text and
you know like usually there's some kind
of like text box right like in which
things get posted and so he could write
it in a way where you know he writes a
text upside uh like you know from top to
bottom right so like first words you
know white space second word third word
etc right
no way
you know i this attack we could actually
try right again sort of the uh the the
fake news uh uh model that that
sebastian was showing right because now
the input is is actually still a
character stream except for from the
perspective of the model it's a
completely perturbed one right because
now you see like character of the first
word white space character the second
word etc right and so
um
and and so like as soon as you start
thinking like this uh you can come up
with many many different attacks uh that
i would argue are much easier to stage
um and so like if i'm going to sort of
rank uh sort of hey what are sort of
real security risks right um then sort
of the adversary examples i don't think
are going to rise to the top because
these uh these things exist like we
don't even need adversarial examples as
a as a service uh to do some of these
things
saying that in in uh in your work uh
you're also i think companies like
google and meta you're also seeing uh
sort of these web scale models that are
being trained on uh something like
billions of images and there's a certain
kind of robustness that you see there is
that telling you something about uh you
know
what the direction in which these models
will have to go
uh to become more robust both just in in
terms of their ability to generalize and
also
to potentially be robust to adversarial
examples
i mean i'd say yes and no um so like in
my own work uh i've been involved in
work where
what we do is we pre-train image
recognition models to
uh predict hashtags from images at a
massive scale so we train these models
on
you know something like five billion
images i think is our largest model to
to predict hashtags and so then if we
take these models and we fine-tune them
on you know sort of typical academic
benchmarks or things like imagenet and
so on then what we find is that these
models are a lot more robust
to variations in the inputs
but this is mostly two natural
variations right so like i just gave
some examples in the um in the text
space in the image space i think there
there's been a nice work out of uh out
of tom dittrich's lab for example
on looking at hey what if i recompress
my image right um or like what if i sort
of uh you know add a little bit of blur
and so on right and so those kinds of
like uh variations also have a um
have a negative effect on on the
recognition accuracy
um of these models not as drastic as
adversarial examples of course right but
but again they're much easier uh things
to do and so
what we find is that these sort of
large-scale models are more robust to
those kinds of natural variations
when you talk about pure sort of white
box adversarial examples
there's not a lot of difference right
like there's slightly more robust but
but really like you know these networks
are
so incredibly uh susceptible to these
examples that
it it i don't think that is sort of a
path that is really going to solve the
uh the adversarial example problem as as
as we're talking about it today
so um sebastian maybe this is a good
place to talk about
your law of robustness because that's
one way in which you have been thinking
about how to
potentially make networks robust to
adversarial examples right yeah
absolutely yeah i can explain what is
the law of robustness and let me say
also that again i agree with florence
and in particular you know i just want
to say that from my perspective my
interest in universal examples is not
about real world security i mean
my interest in the real world anyways is
limited but it's really because it shows
something you know something fundamental
about those networks how they process
information and i want to say that i do
think there is hope to solve them but
certainly not using the approaches that
we've been using in the last you know 10
years so it will need something
dramatically different and that you know
i think we all agree on that so let me
tell you about the the law of robustness
which is related to what lawrence was
saying about you know these larger
models showing a little bit more
robustness so what the the law of
robustness says is that it's it's a
mathematical theorem so as any
mathematical theorem is that it has some
assumptions which we can discuss but in
essence those assumptions are are very
very mild
and you know it it applies very broadly
and it says that the only way for a
model to actually fit
training data
and to fit it smoothly meaning that if
you do a small perturbation of the input
then it gives you a small perturbation
of the output meaning that it is robust
so the only way to have both fitting
data and be robust is to have a number
of parameters much much much larger than
what you would need just to fit the data
so in in very simple terms if you have n
data points okay that corresponds to
kind of n equations you want that on
this image you say it's a pig on this
image you say it's on your plate so you
have kind of n equations that are being
listed
now you know you've learned in like
middle school that if you want to you
know solve a a a problem with three
unknowns you need three equations okay
or to put it the other way around if you
have three equations you need three
unknowns okay to to resolve it so if you
have n equations what you need is n
parameters you need a model that has n
parameters in order to fit okay
this is like you know two century olds
or probably you know two thousand years
old okay so everybody knows if you have
n data points you only need n uh
training parameters now what the law of
robustness says is if in addition to
just this you know requirement that you
fit and training points you're also
asked to be lip sheets lip sheets is
just a technical term to mean robust
that if you do a small perturbation of
the input it gives you a smaller
observation of the output then suddenly
you don't need n parameters but you need
n times d
where d is the dimensionality of the
data which for images would be naively
at least the number of pixels okay so
it's not it's not you you understand d
is like you know a million so this is
very very large so it's not like we're
not saying you know before being robust
you needed n and after being robust you
need like 2m or 3m no no we're saying
you need a million times n so just you
you know vastly vastly
larger type of neural networks and if
you look at actual numbers so this law
for restless you know it gives you like
an actual recipe to compute the size
of the model that you would need it's a
lower bound it's you know you need
something larger than that and you can
compute it for famous data set uh you
know in the machine learning community
like mnist or imagenet and for example
for imagenet you know state-of-the-art
neural network they use roughly 500
million parameters which is very very
large but the law of robustness tells
you that you need at least 10 billion
parameters if you want to solve image
network speed
and and the key point is that this is a
lower bound so what's very very
important to understand about the law of
robustness is also the limitation of the
statement meaning that it's a a
necessity but it's not sufficient it
doesn't tell you that once you reach you
know 10 billion parameters then suddenly
you will be robust
okay so it doesn't tell you that this is
sufficient and this is where i think you
need the new ideas
and lauren i think has a
question or comment on what i just said
yeah a question mostly or actually two
questions i i've read your work
sebastian and it's super
intriguing right because it's it's kind
of
like the result is kind of the opposite
of like the sort of initial intuition of
what you would have right like sort of
as a you know if you've taken an
introduction to machine learning course
like what your thought is like hey you
know like if you increase the number of
perimeters in your model if you can
increase the capacity of your model like
you're you're more bound to like you
know over fits right and and probably if
you're over fit overfitting you're
you're less robust right and and i think
what your result is hinting at is that
it may sort of be the other way around
right and so it sort of in my head sort
of leads to like a minor crisis about
sort of my understanding of um
of machine learning i i guess
you know like since we're here i want to
take the opportunity to sort of ask two
questions on on things where i'm not
fully
sort of clear in my understanding i
guess the first one is
if my understanding is correctly sort of
the result is for
sort of generic data sets right like
which are data sets that are
randomly labeled sort of where you uh
let's say the case where you have a
binary classification problem so what
this means is that like every data point
is sort of uh you you you toss a coin
and you you assign it hats or or tails
and that's um and that's the label and
of course like those are those are quite
different from you know sort of data
sets that we typically look at right
which are not randomly labeled but which
tends to have you know sort of some kind
of structure like you know cats kind of
look similar and they're all labeled as
uh as cats and so so i'm curious to get
your take on like to what how does that
influence um um sort of the result and
and and do these um
um do you sort of see these results um
generalizing to sort of these more
natural data sets where labels are not
uniform uh at random yeah no excellent
question so um
so let me answer the question about the
noise so indeed this applies to the
setting where you know you need to have
noise in in the output that you're
trying to fit and the reason for that is
very simple because if you're trying to
prove a lower bound if you make no
assumption about the structure of the
function then there is a function that
perfectly fits your data and maybe this
function just happens to be smooth
so you will not be able to rule out a
smooth function fitting your data if you
don't make some assumption about you
know the difficulty of the training task
now
this brings us to a very very
interesting point which you know the
reason why we assume noise it's really
for a mathematical reason it's because
noise is kind of you know the epitome of
a difficult function to fit but really
what we would like to have is a notion
of difficulty which is fitted to deep
learning so what we would like to say is
you know for example let's say for
imagenet maybe you know 90 of the data
you can fit it with a very simple model
but then there is ten percent of the
data which remains which is hard which
is difficult to fit and in the lower for
business what we say is difficult just
means
random but of course there is a
maybe a more appropriate notion of
difficult which would be maybe you know
if you run gradient descent on a smaller
network it's not going to be able to fit
this data so you see what i'm trying to
hint at is a more algorithmic notion
of complexity so i think there is a
potential to develop an algorithmic
version of the law of robustness which
would say it's not that you have noisy
data but you have no data which is hard
to fit
through gradient descent on a small
model and then the law of robustness
would say okay the way to get out of
this is to make a bigger model but of
course that's you know much harder i
mean the current law of robustness you
know it's a like the essence of it is a
five lines proof it's something very
very simple you know which relies on a
lot of uh sophisticated mathematics but
that was done you know decades ago but
if you go into this route of algorithmic
law of robustness it's going to be much
much harder and and but but i think it's
doable now you you brought up another
point which is you know it flipped like
the law for business kind of flips on
its side you know traditional uh machine
learning theory and indeed you know i i
was surprised by it myself i mean this
you know we didn't embark on these
projects thinking that we are going to
prove that on the contrary we wanted to
show that you can
find you know small models that fit but
i want to say again one of the huge
limitations of the law of robustness is
that it says nothing about
generalization
it's all about you know if you perfectly
fit your training set and you want to be
lip [ __ ] and you want to be smooth it
does not say anything about you know how
well is it going to generalize
and and and this is you know a big
question of what is the interplay
between adversarial example and
generalization and one of the reasons
why i'm interested in another example is
i think if you remove them
you can actually be uh you know
generalized better and maybe i will just
show you know one picture that i have
which is the work of uh zaywa nalanju
and uh yon julie so let me just show you
this uh
which is this picture
so so this is you know just just just to
give you a hint of why you know if you
remove adversary examples it could
actually generalize better so this is
some convolutional neural network you
know wide resonance and this is layer 29
and you know it's convolutional so i'm
showing you the filters so you have all
those filters and you're not able to
make sense of them they are just kind of
noisy but if you do adversarial training
which is you know one way to to be
slightly more robust then here is what
will be will happen you will kind of
purify your filter you will remove the
noise in the filter and i think this is
actually might be the essence of
adversarial example the essence of
adversary example might be that there is
a lot of noise in the neural network and
the neural network doesn't care too much
about it because you know all these
noises cancel each other out and
eventually in the output it's a tiny
quantity
but if you're an adversary you know
example crafter then you you're going to
correlate with this noise and you're
going to amplify this noise as it's
being processed so one way to remove
adversarial example is to remove this
inherent noise in the network and this
is kind of what does adversarial
training and you see it can give you
much more meaningful
filters so that's one you know
like relation i think between
generalization and adversarial examples
cool okay can i ask one more question
anil on on the of course
this is super interesting by the way i
haven't seen these these results uh
before but like
they're definitely very colorful i i
don't know what they mean yet but uh
i'll think about it um
i guess the other question i had is sort
of on the
um
you know sort of how we define
robustness i guess in in some of these
results right because
you know you said we're sort of focusing
on the lip sheets constant of um um of
the model right and and to me sort of as
i'm thinking about it like that seems
like a little bit of a limited way of
measuring robustness in the sense that
if you have a small lip sheets constant
then i think that implies robustness
right because that that fundamentally
says like if i make a small change to my
input x
that cannot lead to a large change in
the output of um of the model right like
that's sort of the very definition of
the thing but i think the reverse is not
true right like if i have a large
lipschitz constants
uh that doesn't imply that they're going
to be adversarial examples um so so for
example like i can imagine a
a function that is like constant
everywhere except for in like you know
like a teeny tiny uh part of the space
like there i have a huge change and so
now i have a
a model with a large lipstick constant
that i would say
for sort of any
uh
realistic sort of definition of of
robustness would be very robust right
because like the probability of your
test data point landing in like that
that tiny part of the space is is
essentially zero right and so i have a
perfectly robust model
uh but my lipstick's constant is um is
huge and so i'm curious to get your take
on like
you know like is this the right way to
uh uh to measure if if what we
understand uh if we what we want to
understand is sort of susceptibility to
adversarial examples
yeah so no it's not the right thing to
look at uh so this is really so so it's
excellent you know it's again one of the
huge limitations of the law of
robustness and i think now we have
covered all the you know big limitations
of the law for venezuela it's great
because you know all of these
limitations i think you know they they
ask for for more work on it so you're
totally right that you want a more
average notion of smoothness rather than
the worst case notion of looseness but
you know mathematically starting with
the worst case is a natural first step
and then you want to move to the average
case now the issue is mathematically the
law of robustness is not true for
average case smoothness so it's very
easy to see that for example if you take
the expected norm of the gradient
instead of the supremum of the norm of
the gradient you see lipschitz constant
is exactly the supremum of the norm of
the gradient supremum over the entire
space maybe you want a more average like
you know you integrate over the space
what is the norm of the gradient and
this you know mathematically it's called
the sobolev norm and if you try to prove
a lower robustness for so-called norms
you will fail this is not true so you
can actually have small models that fit
the data and that are you know smooth on
average so it
but again it i think what it points you
towards is more algorithmic type of uh
notion of law of robustness you know
what was what is i think kind of
beautiful with the law of representance
is that it's completely universal it
does not talk about algorithms at all it
just says you know you need that number
of parameters and that's it but of
course you know if you don't restrict at
all how you're going to explore you know
this set of large number of parameters
and there is still a lot you can do so
it's kind of very surprising that the
law of robustness is true in the first
place but as soon as i think as you
change on little you know some of the
assumptions then it it falls apart and
it's not true anymore but i think it
doesn't mean the phenomenon is not there
it just means that you need to bring in
the algorithm at that point
this is
very fascinating it basically makes me
wonder uh in fact this is a question
melanie i would love for you to address
you know given how much you think about
ai safety like if if the only way out
for
you know deep neural networks in terms
of being robust
is to get bigger and bigger
are we sort of
locked into an arms race somehow
between people designing
you know deep neural networks for some
tests and those designing
adversarial systems
assuming they're out there designing
them
i don't even know if any real world
examples of such
um
well i think the the
the idea that the only way out is for
neural networks to get bigger and bigger
is assuming that we
kind of stick with the paradigm that
we've been already using but you know
there are other paradigms for
uh ai and for machine learning um
that may not require that you know one
one thing is that you you know construct
contrasting with humans we know that we
have a lot of priors
a lot more than uh deep neural networks
you know we
are
our brains are primed to
represent um
represent our perceptions in rather low
dimensional ways you know
sebastian mentioned that
he's looking at high you know the the
representation is very high dimensional
it's maybe the number of pixels in the
image but that's not how we humans
represent uh visual information we uh
intrinsically divide the world into
objects
we intrinsically
um
have a kind of low dimensional
representation of a scene in terms of
objects in their relationships we also
have
not just this
kind of
model fitting way of of
kind of learning about
about the world we we have
more of more of a causal understanding
at least even
subconsciously you know that
certain kinds of light
uh reflecting off certain kinds of
surfaces has a certain kind of um impact
sort of like the shadow
optical illusion i showed you know we
know about the co you know the cause of
something looking different because of a
shadow
and all of those priors and causal
modeling i think can actually
inform the robustness
of of a of a visual vision system
and i think those kinds of
ways of
of developing an architecture might
be very different from what we are doing
now with purely statistical
uh curve fitting essentially
with without any without a large number
of pr priors and a large uh you know
kind of a more sophisticated
uh conceptual architecture
so i i would say that you know
generally in ai today there's this big
debate going on
about you know is
scaling our models bigger and bigger
kind of the answer to all of the
limitations we see and a lot of people i
think believe that you know and there's
been some evidence that scaling really
does have a big impact you know seeing
these giant generative models for
language and
images and so on that are amazing but
i would contest that i would say that
certain limitations are not going to be
overcome by scaling but they're going to
be overcome by new kinds of
architectures probably inspired by
natural intelligence
so i don't know if that addresses your
question
but that was kind of what i was thinking
of well while this discussion was going
on well i think that brings us nicely uh
full circle because we started with
human vision
so
peter i think has some audience
questions uh that we should address
so
peter would you like to ask them for us
yes um
there are there are four so so far and
uh you know just to
remind folks there's a q a panel um uh q
a button in the in the zoom panel you're
welcome to to add your questions there
um the first one is um uh about
a general general question about the
reverse engineering of adversarial
images um this was asked before
uh seb's
uh explanation so maybe we'll skip that
it seems at least one possible reason
that these kinds of models are fooled by
adding noise to visual images is because
we designed them to include too too many
visual details to process compared to
the way that humans process the same
images which perhaps does not include as
much detailed inspection and simply ask
just to recognize objects
so this is
yeah so so i guess this question is
probably hinting at some defenses which
you know would say okay what about if
you project you know your input onto
maybe the manifold of images or just you
know maybe blur it a little bit and you
know maybe this will destroy whatever
adversal example you've put in because i
think the thinking probably in the
question is adversarial examples they
look like this very high frequency
type of information that you have added
to the image and the bad news is again
you know no defenses out there is
working and so even you know if you've
built your system so that you project on
some manifold or does some blurring then
you can still do gradient descent with
respect to that you know being included
in the pipeline and it will find an
universal example
um
yeah i i would also interpret the
question as as this question of
dimensionality representations that you
know
do we
when you're looking at all of the
details of the image kind of pixel
including all of the pixels equally um
maybe that uh presents ways of
vulnerability that it wouldn't would not
be presented if you had more bias
towards certain kinds of things like
objects
had an object-based representation
okay
one more here um
uh
ang chuman asks generating adversarial
examples as shown here assumes that we
have access to the network
um what if i do not have access to the
network but i can run as many examples
through the network as i want
i can maybe take take that one um so so
um so sort of what you're what you're
referring to on schumann is is what is
known as sort of black box attacks right
so these are attacks where you don't
assume um access to sort of the model
weights itself right and so you cannot
compute
the gradients with respect to the inputs
that you would need in order to stage
the effect that
that sebastian
explains
but in those cases like as long as you
have access to
sort of outputs of the model like given
in inputs
you can still stage the text because for
example what you can imagine doing is
like
you sort of take a pixel and you change
it in one direction and you change it in
the other direction
and you look at like what happens to the
output of the model right like does the
the probably go upward or down right and
you sort of you randomly pick a pixel
each time um and you see in which
direction you need to move uh the pixel
um and this is uh what is known as
coordinate descent right so it's
you know trying to uh uh sort of
minimize the uh the likelihood of of the
prediction
right uh without having access to um to
the gradients now that seems very
inefficient right because like you you
may have to do like millions of of
queries because there's so many pixels
in an image uh but in practice you can
make these attacks
quite efficient uh because images are
relatively low dimensional right and so
what you could do is like you could do
some kind of like dimension reduction
like imagine running pca on a large set
of images and now you have some like
relatively low dimensional basis in
which you could do these
uh discoordinate descents uh like
attacks um and that in in practice
allows you to
sort of successfully change the
prediction on um
on an image or generate an adversarial
perturbation typically in a couple of
hundred of queries for uh for image
recognition systems
and then there are also like things uh
so so this came up already a little bit
in the conversation right like there was
some degree of transferability um of
adversarial attacks sort of between
models right and so if you had access
maybe
not to the exact model that you're
attacking but you had some kind of sense
of what that model is right so you had
some kind of like surrogate model um you
could use that model and basically like
you know sort of use the gradients uh uh
for that model sort of as an you know as
an estimate for like what will happen in
the uh the model that you're actually
trying to attack and and this is often
quite uh quite effective as well it's
obviously not as powerful as a white box
attack so often what that means is that
the size of the perturbation that you
need to do in order to make the attack
successful has to be a bit larger and so
sometimes it becomes sort of perceptible
um but at the same time like you know
sort of if you have like a bit of
you know sort of salt and pepper noise
in your image like that is not you know
perceptually that's not really uh not
really changing anything um and so in
short like
yes i mean you can do sort of uh attacks
in these in these black box settings and
they're and they're quite effective if
you have a couple of hundred of um of
queries against the model
yeah i'll just add there have been some
groups who have looked at genetic
algorithms or evolutionary computation
for generating black box attacks
especially
if you can
have a lot of queries and you can
certainly uh people have done that as
well
it kind of speaks to lawrence's earlier
point that there's a hundred to one
ratio of papers
look doing attacks versus defense
yeah i i actually i still to this day i
don't understand this it's right like
you know sort of you
in particular if you're an academic and
you do research like don't you want to
work on sort of the side of the good
guys uh like rather than inside the
background yeah it's easier to do the
adversary attacks on the defense
like to do the defense you also have to
do the adversary
so
you have to play both sides to be able
to do this yes but we're researchers
right like is it a hard thing the
exciting thing
yeah you're right
any more questions peter yes um uh there
there are several more um so oh there's
one here asking about a the distinction
between um
the generation of adversarial examples
and the generation of counterfactual
examples so elaborating on
on this relationship
to uh causal inference
this is from austin
i'm not sure what they mean by
counterfactual examples
yeah so maybe uh
maybe austin can elaborate on the
on the the question question
um okay let's move on to a chance to do
that let's move on to don's question um
it's about
[Music]
calibrating confidence so might it be
possible to sensitize deep learning
systems to their vulnerability to
adversarial examples so they could
better calibrate the confidence that
they have in their accuracy
yeah it doesn't
uh i mean yes of course that's a natural
thing to to suggest uh again like those
suggestions are kind of defense
suggestions and and people out there
have been trying to to do that but
none of them work basically as as soon
as you can write down you know an
objective function
then you're going to be able to do great
and descent on it and and fool it and
and you know it goes back to what
melanie was saying about you know maybe
you need a some paradigm shift if you
really want to you know
remove those adversary examples and you
cannot do it within the current setting
that's that's plausible
okay and then we have a question from
chad saying
asking about this this discussion about
uh smoothness or lipsticks properties to
what extent is it true that human
perception is lipschitz with respect to
these
digital pixels
that is can we find a picture that looks
sort of like a door with a low distance
from a picture that looks much more like
an emu
yes i'm curious
about what melanie will say to this
because one one question i have is of
course you know the human visual system
as she was saying you know there is a
temporal dynamic like you don't you know
you know i have suddenly an image in
front of you and you have to decide what
it is but i wonder you know i i don't
think this experiment exists out there
but what if you know you wake up
somebody from a coma and you show them
you know a picture and you have
adversaries
it like can you you know make you
believe that the dog is a chimpanzee or
something like that and probably when
you wake up from a coma you're not ready
for this experiment but uh i i don't
know is there something like that out
there yeah i mean i saw an ex a paper
with an experiment where they they
limited the time people could look at
the picture you know they're showing
people
adversarial examples and asking them to
classify them and
limited the amount of time and you know
there was some evidence that
people were fooled also
not as badly as machines but i've also
seen some
kind of um criticism of of the
experimental
uh
methods that for for that study so you
know it's something that could be
addressed by manipulating you know the
time you have to look at things but i
i don't know if that question has been
fully answered
one one other relevant study i've seen
recently i think it was an icml this
year out of james d carlos lab was a
a study where
essentially they
staged a black box attack um sort of
against like an individual neuron in uh
in a macaque
and what they showed was that sort of
through small perturbations um in the um
in the inputs they were able to sort of
substantially change the firing rates of
like uh an individual neuron in um
in the inferior temporal cortex so that
goes a little bit in this direction
i'm no expert on this so so melanie you
should give your take on it as well like
my sort of the main question i had
around it is like it's changing the
firing rate sort of of an individual
neuron i don't think it would change the
recognition like there weren't sort of
any results suggesting that
uh the uh that the macaque would sort of
recognize something else or or maybe
just would take longer to recognize
which i think would already be
you know sort of
a a huge result and presumably that has
to do with the fact that
you know sort of in um in something like
itl like there isn't sort of a single
neuron that represents the you know
ostrich or cat class right but this is
sort of a a distributed uh
representation of the
um of the class right and so you'd
really have to change all the neurons in
order to to really flip the the
recognition um but i'm curious to get
your take on it yeah i don't i don't
know
i i don't think you can you know there's
so much redundancy
uh
in in the brain that
you obviously can't just attack a single
neuron um
but i don't know how far you could get
with that kind of approach
but i was going to say there's also
another study that um
came out of i think it was um
at tommy poggio's lab at mit where they
were showing that a neural network that
model that had some kind of foveation
you know the way that we kind of move
our eyes
and are able to like focus on different
parts of the image so what was more
robust to
adversarial examples than
the network without foveation
you know that's still a preliminary
study but it's interesting putting in
some dynamics and feedback
all right going back to
austin's question
says i've seen counterfactual examples
described as
a counterfactual explanation of a
prediction describes the smallest change
to the feature values that changes the
prescription i'm sorry changes the
prediction to a predefined output uh so
you know this is certainly
very much in the same spirit as the sort
of uh
tiny perturbations that we're
considering here i don't know if anybody
wants to
add anything to to that
yeah i guess in general you you would
think that maybe you know one solution
to address our example is to you know
finding the image what causes you know
uh the image to contain an elephant like
you want to find you know the root cause
of it and then you know you would
imagine that maybe a counterfactual
example maybe is something that attacks
you know this would cause itself rather
than doing something you know spurious
on the on the noise maybe that's what
the question is saying
uh to which i don't know what to answer
but but it's a good question
okay and we have one from vinod uh
asking about strong negative results
with respect to defenses to robustness
i.e when is it impossible to be robust i
guess perhaps you know in addition to
the negative result you told us about
so
yeah
i mean there are many many results out
there but the question is always for
those negative results what is the
assumption so no there are results out
there that says and i have worked on
them like uh you know
what is the reason why networks can be
robust maybe it's computationally hard
you know because you're allowing the
adversar the adversary exponential power
you allow the adversary to search you
know a high dimensional space and to
find you know any perturbation there so
maybe defending against this high
dimensional adversary is just
computationally hard you know in the
sense of p versus np and it's very easy
to craft i mean not very easy but it's
easy to craft example and for those of
the audience to know about this you know
just using plural random generators it's
easy to craft example where you know
it's a classification task where there
exists it there exists a robust
classifier it's not like it doesn't
exist it exists
but it's computationally hard to find it
so you can classify the problem easily
if you're not asking to be robust in in
computational uh you know if
computationally efficiently but as soon
as you want to be robust you're not
computationally efficient so you know
there are results out there like this
there are also results saying like for
other examples maybe you need more
samples you know maybe the sample
efficiency is more limited so you need
you need you know more number of data
but again like whether it's the sample
efficiency or the computational
efficiency these are very specific
examples like carefully crafted example
kind of like optical illusion
and the point for example of the lower
robustness is that it's not like optical
illusion is something much more general
that applies you know more broadly and
that says you know that the model size
has to be big
there there's a related question that um
we touched on earlier which is the
trade-off between
adversarial robustness and
generalization
you know that it seems empirically that
when you make a network robust through
adversarial training say it becomes l
its generalization performance goes down
and i don't know if there's any sort of
rigorous mathematical results on that
no there is definitely but um
again in limited setting like you know
they will show you examples where
necessarily you have this trade-off but
personally if you ask me my belief which
is not a mathematical belief but my my
belief is that eventually solving
adversary examples will help also
classical generalization but not solving
them through the way we're doing it
right now which is too limited and not
solving it anyway so
well um i think we're uh coming to the
end of our allotted time so i would uh
like very much to ask each of you your
closing thoughts
i mean like i guess the thing that comes
to mind in terms of a question to ask
you is
given all that we've talked about
how
how would you
want to continue research on adversarial
examples like what should you be
focusing on or is it worth focusing on
them at all in the way the academic
community is doing right now
briefly you know you know we've gone
to gone into it in fair amount of detail
but just as a closing thought melanie
would you like to start
um sure so
i you know i'm a big fan of
biologically inspired approaches and i
think that it would be interesting to
try more biologically inspired
approaches to robustness
foveation was one thing you know
maybe uh
putting in more
prior assumptions
uh
putting in more causal
uh
constraints and so on
and i think that those experiments you
know a lot of them still
remain to be done and i think that would
that's a possible way forward
lawrence
yeah i would say like
very much uh i i think i would i would
encourage folks to think sort of very
clearly on you know sort of why are you
working on on a particular direction
right like we mentioned a couple of
times there sort of many many uh attack
papers
if you sort of write a paper where you
come up with like a slightly different
variation of like an attack that like
you know sort of
you know the uh is five percent more
effective at like a very small l2 norm
perturbation or something like that
i don't see what that sort of how that
brings us forward in terms of you know
either uh our understanding of um of
deep networks um sort of
sort of how robustness relates to to
generalization as sebastian was was
talking about
and i don't see how it it brings us
forward in terms of um
in terms of sort of making sort of re
current real world systems more robust
and so i would mostly encourage folks uh
sort of working in this space and there
there are many uh because there are
thousands of thousands of papers a year
coming out on on this topic
uh to think carefully about like what is
what is the goal that we're really
trying to uh to get to and and what is
the work that's um
that is sort of most likely to uh to
bring me closer to uh to that goal and i
think if if the community does that
then
uh
um well some other work will be will be
different i think and then maybe
sebastian actually will make more
progress because he can use a lot of
help in um
with the law of robustness and
and sort of you know figuring out the
many caveats
around it
and sebastian your closing thoughts yeah
so for me uh so there are two directions
that i'm really excited about uh you
know in the space of uh adversaries
examples one of them is you know to
overcome all the limitations that we
have discussed uh of the law of
robustness i think there is you know a
lot more to be discovered there and but
these are not i i want to warn people
that these are not low hanging fruits i
mean it's these are difficult questions
when once you want to put the algorithm
in it and you know so yeah maybe that's
all i would say these are not low
hanging fruits you you will have to work
a little bit hard and and i'm not
working on it myself right now the other
direction that i am working on uh myself
at the moment is to imbue neural
networks with a little bit more sparsity
so as you know the last picture that i
slowed on i showed on my side by the way
andrew and julie is that you know maybe
at the same example they really come
from correlating with the noise that
happens in the processing of the neural
network and maybe you know if you can
turn off some amount of this noise
through sparsity through killing some of
those you know like the the most naive
ways to kill you know low weights but
this is like you know level zero of the
idea you can you know maybe kill off
some neurons that are just spurious
neurons or maybe you know entire paths
like you know we haven't talked about
transformer models but you know maybe in
transformer models you have many heads
and many some of those heads they are
doing exploration at the beginning
through gradient descent but you want to
remove them at the end so basically
trying to prune networks in order to get
uh better robustness i think this is a
very promising uh direction which is not
paradigm shifting so you know it's it's
still maybe achievable uh and and you
could make a lot of progress with that
okay well um this has been a fabulous
discussion thank you so much all of you
for participating melanie sebastian
lawrence
thank you peter for
helping us put this together
and uh and thank you to everyone at
simon's for making this happen
so it's been a real pleasure having you
uh
in this discussion today so thank you
all yeah thank you to our audience
let me add my thanks to you anil and to
uh melanie sebastian and lawrence uh
that was a really lively discussion it's
given us a lot to think about um and
thanks to the audience for uh for all
their contributions
all right we hope to see you again soon
thanks all thank you bye everyone
bye
you